هل يعجبك شكلي الجديد المختلط
لقد قطعت شوطًا طويلاً منذ أن
أصدرت Microsoft أول هولولين منذ ثلاث سنوات على
الرغم من أن العديد من المستهلكين لن
يروا أبدًا التغييرات التي أدت إلى
Hololens - وذلك لأن هذه
الأجهزة تركز على مكان العمل وليس على
المنازل  الهدف هو ما يسميه
منشئ Hololens Alex kipman عمال الخط الأول
تلك الوظائف والصناعات مثل
الرعاية الصحية والميليشيات التي
تتطلب عملاً يدويًا ولكنها ستستفيد
من المساعدات البصرية ، على
سبيل المثال ، سأعمل وأصلح
هذا الشيء جيدًا
أمام  أنا هو هذا المنفاخ الضخم الذي
يدفع الهواء عبر نظام الصرف الصحي
وما تسمح لي هذه الزجاجات بفعله
هو إلقاء نظرة على ما يحدث داخل
هذه التروس حتى أتمكن من الحصول على فكرة
عما سأفعله عندما أقوم
بالتشغيل والإصلاح  هذه الآلة ولكن رؤية
كل شيء أولاً من خلال نظام الواقع المختلط ،
لذا فهي الآن توضح لي
كيف ستخرج الأجزاء من هذا
الترس العملاق أمامي.
في الواقع ، يتم القيام بذلك يدويًا ، لذا عليك
فقط إرشادي وإظهار
ما يجب القيام به ، لكنني سأقوم
بالعمل الفعلي بيدي ،
وسعر ثلاثة آلاف ونصف دولار
موجه للشركات بدلاً من
المستهلكين العاديين ، حيث أن التكلفة تجلب
تقدمًا كبيرًا  كان أحد
الانتقادات الرئيسية للهولولينز هو
عرضه الميداني المحدود للهولولين - أكثر
من الضعف ، كما أن لديه مستشعرات لتتبع العين
زادت الدقة من
ما يعادل 720 لكل عين إلى
2k هائل وتحسين التوازن والوزن من خلال
استهداف أصغر بكثير
الجمهور الموجه نحو الأعمال التجارية مهدت Microsoft
الطريق لتحقيق عوائد أكبر في الواقع المختلط